Airborne divincenzo blocked by Davis
final seconds Reeves it'll kind of a
ghost
[Applause]
and then Reeves
three of his 13 points here in the first
half a dramatic end
to the second quarter and the Lakers
back up by 10.
Payton's back in he picked up two quick
fouls Reeds behind the back draws the
back
Curry allowed me to have this dance
Austin Powers the crossover behind the
back takes the contact
he's got morantha on him here comes the
double team aldama achimore kicks it out
to an open range for three puts it in as
the shot clock expires
and I'm still okay if hachimura is the
shooter Reeves fakes Reeves behind the
back hachimura three-pointer puts it in
Brewing hachimura the greatness of
Reeves with that behind the back pass on
the money and Reeves on the money with
the jump shot 16 for Reeves he continues
his terrific play Lakers clinging to a
three-point lead drizzlies trying to win
without Moran Reeves a three
[Applause]
Reeves from way downtown
[Music]
Reeves 21 points three assists gets
inside off balance Shepherd got it a
goal of his way keeps a smaller defender
on his back elevates gets the bounce
this just in Austin Powers
still is still an added boner there it
is
so Dylan misses his first two
three-point shots Reeves
chance at a three-point play well part
of the issue too when you shoot a long
jump shot the long rebound
now you're
opposition has a chance to get out and
transition and Austin Reeds
Bane around Davis to Tillman knocked
Away by LeBron Reeves two on two reads
the trailing chains floating and getting
it Schroeder the screen James crossover
to the corner extra pass Reeves he
drives Reeves lays it in still down six
three and a half to play
James the Reeves Reeves throws it up
that's gone
raised from downtown nine straight
points it's a three-point game
Austin Reeves a three Austin Reeds from
downtown and it's back to three again
he's down on the floor down the other
end
holding on to that left leg now slowly
gets up reads a three-pointer backs it
in Austin Reeves from downtown it's a
two-point game
[Applause]
[Music]
come in for the Lakers Reeves left open
sets fires and in Boston Reeves got 20
again and it's a tie day Denver wants
time out 109 104 with two and a half to
play James up top Schroeder Reeves finds
away puts it in Reeves with the answer
of three-pointer and it's back to two
five Maine sprays it out to Moran Corner
three is short Reeves On The Run they
got a three on two side step layup
timeout Memphis
La is live first saw Austin Reeves he
said man this kid is wild but he made
Moves like this in training campus so
coach I got every bit of this in my bag
go ahead Austin there is Walker now it's
off to Reeves holiday with him yeah it's
in the way shot clock at seven
foreign
[Applause]
left to right oh my goodness Austin Reed
oh he's posting that on Instagram
tonight believe you me oh he said I
learned that in Arkansas when I was
growing up for Mom and Dad who both
played college basketball in Arkansas
that's front Reeves Corner that comes up
way short Austin though oh pass what a
pass to Gabriel after the Miss Austin
Stayed with it
again us and Reese and with the left
hand behind his back too to Wendy and
Gabriel who
throws it home nicely done and then
Reeves after that possession
here's Westbrook in the lane Lakers have
been scoreless the last three and a half
minutes Davis not even looking to score
just gave it up now gets it back and
takes it to the rim great behind the
back pass the third taken by Austin
looks left goes behind his back
[Applause]
dribble's behind his back to avoid the
defender and then the pass with the left
to LeBron to just lay it up and lay it
in that's just a nicely run fast break
all right
Schroeder gives it right back Reeves oh
oh my goodness what an acromatic move by
Austin Reeves time to experience our
extraordinary play of the game presented
by Mata Quest an incredible move by
Austin wherever he plays yeah he's
definitely a good leader a guy having to
come off your bench now bro
contagious pays it off back defensively
Austin Reeves in a mad Sprint to get
back another look at that point where
Austin freed himself up for the
mid-range and the ball is going out of
bounds and they know somebody's running
after they just stand and wait Austin
right over his head to score count it
and a foul left-hander creating a shot
like this he he really does a good job
of concentrating on the Target and
making plays and making three-point
opportunity
shoes Troy Brown Jr two guys on Anthony
Davis so somebody has to do something
well they put the move on to the ball
and it's been scoring on him good
control to get six to shoot he's got to
get into his action they're going to try
to cut him off LeBron into the corner
Austin again Austin Reeves plus time and
it's night and Night Out Stu that that
not only we talk about it but the Lakers
talk about it themselves 2 A.D and do
something yeah maybe he actually knows
that there's a land in by Reed oh and he
does the two small but you got guys that
you might depend on and trust that can
snyme me a team's run Graves the fifth
and straight for the Lakers yeah and
Austin reads the Catalyst of this run
right now missing Reed rebound goes
between two players Another Love throw
it down King
LeBron from Austin reads timeout
briefs spins struggle shot cattle and
one what a shot from Austin Reeds off
balance gets knocked down and a chance
for a three-point play turn around after
that awful third quarter but it only
were down by five Schroeder with speed
now
it down Austin
15.4 remaining Schroeder runs into the
backcourt he was open they couldn't get
it to him oh Westbrook
[Music]
this one's almost stolen a dangerous
pass and it threads the needle yeah he
did I thought he definitely had him and
this was dangerous but with that small
[Music]
[Applause]
LeBron I read the laundry yes got it
Russ Reeves ball take here he comes to
the rim scores
and won Austin Reeves what the I'm
talking about his rust goes is three
passes it clock's going down and just as
he gets fired and lets it go trying to
try a reverse which doesn't go Craig got
in the way here comes Reeves who tries
and will take it and get it to go a
21-point game Sunday against San Antonio
a career high
[Music]
entirely different speed than the Lakers
but
Memphis now in front 42-38 the Lakers
have gone cold Reeves
a chance for four
[Music]
doing it with two two-way players out
there who have given them a big lift all
year Austin Reeves with the reverse
geez we just hit awesome you mentioned
it's due he's been the Difference Maker
creates
and headset as we look at Austin Reeves
with his control over the top of Markel
folks
16 for Austin Reeves to go along with
swim through that time loses Joe Reed
first layup is good by AR that's the way
you read the defense throw it in nice
job by Austin Reeves has a missed five
for five on the floor three for three
from Milan